there was a really just telling moment
on the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC journalist Dana Milbank
talking about how scary it is that we
might actually get transparency from
this government they love trans just not
transparency speaker Kevin McCarthy is
under Fire for sharing about 44
000 hours of surveillance camera footage
from January 6 with Fox News host Tucker
Carlson other media organizations
including NBC News have demanded access
to the tapes as well the speaker is more
than just the political leader they also
oversee the day-to-day administration of
the capital including security is there
something unprecedented about what
McCarthy has done here Dana
yeah I mean day after day it seems that
he breaks a precedent after precedence
look I understand why the other media
are asking for the same thing the truth
is this doesn't belong in the public
domain for anybody
that's the line This doesn't belong in
the public domain we are told that there
was an Insurrection that the United
States almost fell on that day despite
these people having no plans Apparently
one guy had a Lego set he didn't even
bring it of the capital AOC was freaking
out but we should not know about this
stuff
I take it you're not surprised Libby
they're better than us and they know
right
yeah these are our superiors and we must
bow down before their Superior judgment
um I for one I'm glad that there's going
to be some transparency I think that the
people who went into the capital and the
people who were around the Capitol and
the journalists who were not
credentialed but were documenting what
was going on that day have been
substantially ill-treated and ignored
and I think that that's really a shame
especially when you compare it to the
sweetheart deals and uh you know
compassionate treatment that was given
to the rioters in the summer of 2020 I'm
thinking specifically of the ones in
Portland uh against whom I I believe so
many charges were dropped even though
they were trying to set the federal
buildings on fire repeatedly like like
night after night for more than 100
nights I believe it was I think it ended
up being something like 120 nights yeah
this went on yeah and I'd like to see
what was really going on there's been a
lot of talk about perhaps there were
federal agents involved if the
government can disprove that then maybe
they ought to there has been talk about
and this is something that you've seen
on Tucker Carlson as well uh Capitol
police officers opening doors and all of
this kind of stuff what was really going
on what was the relationship there what
kind of encouragement were these people
getting from law enforcement if that was
happening and uh yeah the way that they
have used January 6 as a cudgel to beat
anyone who disagrees with the leftist
progressive narrative means that we get
to see literally every second of footage
because they're going to continue to use
this against all of us who don't agree
with the Biden Administration for years
we're just seeing that you know they
keep coming out with stuff about that as
they're starting to quiet down and their
little commission had to get disbanded
at the end of the last Congress we
haven't heard as much about it but I do
respect and appreciate McCarthy for
giving over this these yeah and you know
I I will give the devil his due here I
mean McCarthy if he wanted to do this
I suppose in the most clean way maybe he
could have just released it all together
whatever that means you know just put it
out there on the internet and let people
go through it or he could have said hey
I'm giving it to Tucker but I'm also
giving it to Anderson Cooper or
something if you'd like more sane takes
on our insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
round tables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell